Right i will i'm harry freeman. And. I'm forty eight. An aquarian. An aquarian monkey in the chinese.
Why of looking at astrology. And i now work. As the director of psychiatric services. Up in this part of the state.
Running a psychiatric unit and. The community services are added here. I've always been interested in psychiatry that.
That was my. That's my career. To some extent my passion i guess. And i came to the aquarius festival.
Because of my connection at the time. To student politics which had tike in a rather theatrical.
Sort of term and i think. By the early seventy's of course i was. University from not in sixty to sixty seven.
In medical school. And the moratoria. About vietnam and now sorts of things were happening.
When i was beginning my internship system medicare so i was active in left wing politics and still active.
To some extent dean. As i said the more theatrical parts of student politics consequently.
I was good friends with with graham don's done and with various people who were still on campus.
Even though i'd left campus. And so i was identified i saw i identified myself.
With that group of people who were talking about the kind of culture. That was.
A peculiar sort of liaison i suppose between the left. In this rather more and call group of people.
But i guess for me. I ride through medical school and even then. As a young doctor.
And certainly in the beginning of my training in psychiatry. I didn't have the same connection. To doctors.
As many of my colleagues deed. For some reason.
I couldn't mike this sort of tribal connection to the rest of the doctors.
That a lot of people did not that i wasn't a good doctor and highly regarded and. And.
Fond of the whole idea of being a doctor.
But it certainly didn't satisfy our need for a tribal connection which i felt. And which. People like gras am.
And the more active an interesting student politicians. Did represent for me.
So when i suppose it was like not in seventy two. Due to my. Various her listener janick connections to grier.
He talked about doing at festival. At name been. I immediately said well.
I guess we all need some sort of medical people lay you would remember.
Now you might not remember me but i would stock. The film of woodstock. My.
Quite a bit of the sort of medical problems that arose in the context of a bad trip spittal side cuts and bruises
and god knows what all that happens when. Thousands of people suddenly find themselves.
Together in fairly unsanitary conditions. So i said to graham that i would.
Coordinate the the medical side of things for the festival. And i just gathered a group of.
My fellow psychiatric registrars as a matter of fact we were all. In fact writing.
And said you know if you want to come up to newman for the festival. And so we went up on a preliminary visit.
To nimbin and discovered that there was a hospital labeled it had been closed for many years and there was just.
A sister.
Working at the hospital sort of keeping it open because there wasn't even a doctor in the town it was a dying town
and too small to support a time doctor.
And we came to the beis hospital in lease more with very long hair and short shorts and beads and all the rest of it
and. Beads. And said to a rather astonished. Administration here at the hospital that i'd better open this hospital up.
And that we would indeed. Manage and woman that and look after it for the time of the festival.
And strangely enough despite have bizarre appearance all that.
I required was that we show evidence that we were indeed doctors and there i were i stopped the hospital with nurses
and i handed over the hospital to me and my cohorts. So there i was at name been with the rest of my tribe.
And friends. I was sort of wandering between the. The camp that we my dad or malcolm creek and the hospital and.
So i was. Very much there. And. More and more. I guess. The idea of.
Rejecting the dominant paradigm and being able to rejected by thing practical
and impersonal terms was stamped in for me. So i saw myself. I was living in group homes and.
Communal houses in sydney any why. Well that married. Me and my wife.
But lived in houses where there were lots of other people living so the idea of living with a group of like minded
souls rather than just on foreign media was again stamping for me at the festival so a few of my media friends bought a
farm. While we were there. It cost us nine thousand dollars for the two hundred acres at nieman.
And of course the locals thought we were absolute foods for. Even paying that much money for this place of dirt.
But we were quite captivated with it and we could. All say that. We did want to live communally and most of us filled.
That one way or another we could probably find some sort of employment up here.
Certainly from a i knew there was no doubt. Because there was no psychiatric service up here in.
Nine hundred seventy three. At all. And one of the other doctors that i brought up with me. Decided as soon as he hit.
Town that he indeed was going to come up here in town and start a psychiatric service
and that he would need of a friend and a partner to do that.
So i would simply remind for me to go back to sydney then and qualify which i did the next year in seventy four.
And then i was doing a research project in sydney.
So i didn't actually come here and stopped work till seventy five or.
From seventy three on i mean every holiday since we had the fam up here. We would have.
Come here and indeed one of or one of two of the people moved up. By the end of seventy three.
And so we had to farm and we decided to leave. Commune only and. To try to share as much as we cood that stuff i share.
The tribal. Knight share of the migration.
Was pretty clear to me and my friends that was what we wanted a sense of community that.
In fact pretty actively rejected the dominant culture. But it's very hard to reject the dominant culture so we weren't.
I mean we decided to get on to the green and we indeed i think the families were top to electricity
when we bought it and we've been chopped down a telephone pass or anything like that.
So what we did i guess as a group of people who were.
You know capable of feeling comfortable about a level of compromise and accommodation are we can
and i'm joined the tribe here and. Various of us got part time jobs and i was just tired of time on the fam and.
We tried as much as we cood. To to to reject.
Simple sort of nuclear living and nuclear aspirations or nuclear family aspirations. And so that's how i got here.
You know what will work. Yes. Ah yes there's no doubt that the festival worked for me. As an affirmation of.
The possibility of. Really feeling a sense of belonging. With a very disparate group of people.
Who were indeed pretty different from all of the groups that i've now. Before then the possible groups i mean.
I could join the medical try. But that would never interested me. I could have gone into politics.
Because i was interested in that you know. At university but that particular trial. Didn't grab me.
My parents were both. Successful schoolteachers and i could have continued on as. The fairly successful.
You know upper middle class doctor which is what i would have liked me to bury and and move in that. Tribe. But.
For my for me the the dark smoking. Mushroom. Eating. Tribe had much more appeal. And also there.
There was quite enough. Well intellectual stimulation from a in that. Frankly i felt but.
The group of people who i was who i was living with. Were wonderfully.
Creatively intelligent and brod how mean i were not. In any why. Behind any group of people with respect to having.
The sort of intellectual con contact that i wanted it saying to me that i were to the forefront in the area of ideas in
in in in an enormous number of areas that were a very very rich tapestry of human beings.
There was no doubt in my mind that out of the group that i belong to and really that i still belong to.
Cyle the festival. Might it. Obvious that that. Tribal connectedness was a viable. To me provided i. I migrated and.
You know hung on even through all the the ambiguity of. Of the thing because it would. It would be.
It's not true to suggest that we had an ideology even.
The counterculture and rose akon sort of writers would suggest there was some sort of ideology.
That's not really true i mean. By sickly it was too.
To not follow the dominant paradigm i mean it was a negative ideology that everything. That anybody else was.
Was hanging on to. Was probably useless.
If you do have an ideology that essentially a negative one which i think is what we had. With all sorts of people.
Pronouncing on their particular. Positive ideology and sighing. That was what it was all about.
I mean you really had to be able to tolerate an enormous amount of ambiguity.
You know there are many people who i'm sure you will talk to who will side that it was absent that that name
and was about alternative energy or that. Name been was about. The hot. Saw that name and was about. Smoking dive.
And indeed it was about all of those sorts of things but i was never. I never felt it was about anything in particular.
Other than the rejection of the dominant paradigm. Because. And i was in my ignorance i spazz i.
I felt certain that the dominant paradigm was a fire. And both. For individual human beings and for the planet.
So i was confident that that what most people were doing. Was not really helping either them or the planet.
But as for what we should do. In the face of that problem.
I wasn't too confident and i just went along for the ride with a number of. The the things that because i'm.
Focal points. You know. For for the new trial.
I'm just as sure as i was then which i suppose some people would say is too sure. But i don't feel absolutely certain.
But i'm certainly. About i am as sure as i was then that. The why humans. Rely to each other. And the structures.
Through which. Most humans rely to each other in australia and indeed in the whole of the western world.
Bad for humans and bad for the planet. Yes i'm pretty sure that we were right.
That most of the things that were happening were wrong.
But i don't know that we've come up with any particularly brilliant. Alternative structures.
You know we've had no impact on the media we've had no impact on commercial ism.
Consumerism or we've had a little bit of an impact on two things i guess as a local at a local level. We've had a.
I think. A leading role in. Alerting the plan. To the environmental consequences of weston. Society.
There are things like that which i think. Very powerful and very very important.
But apart from that capacity to turn round i think a lot of people as far as the environment is concerned.
There are not too many things that we could have been outstandingly successful in. In china this terrible.
Slide that wherry in both as individuals and of course as a planet. Its own.
I'm a bit naïve ice buys but i i wouldn't we filed i would just. See the problems. Of creating china which be.
Well massive i mean. There are in any particular system. There are three back loops.
Invisible feedback loops that are operating to keep things running the waythe. And. To bring about some china and.
Even the sort of structures that are dominating you know. Al life at the moment i think is something that.
That's simply beyond a small group of people i mean i think we're going to need a lot of luck.
Right now for this terrible process that we're all in guy had seen. To decelerate i don't see. I. What the maybe.
What impact the media have on my life at the moment but i suspect it's profound. And yet i can't see any why.
In the past twenty five years that i've been a conscious create creature in
and interacting with the media i can't see any why in which. I could either find out what they are really doing to me.
Or. See how i could impact them other than the why that i have. So i feel pretty powerless in the face of the media.
And i thought that the rod would. I guess.
There are forms of communication i suppose i should sign that i just saw per vice if and. And at the same time.
Undiscernible.
And i will to be teased out
and of a components that i feel pretty helpless so i don't know that there is anything more that we as a tribe could
have done maine other than the frankland or saif to write or. Sti in a pot of the year which is visually.
Very beautiful which is not. A city because i don't think cities are good places for humans to grow.
So we've successfully. My urban rural migration. And stuck around. And become useful and. To some extent.
An accepted part of that other tribe
and now i think we've done about as well as we could hope to do i don't see how else
or how more profoundly we could have impacted. Either locally. The last. Same for the national saying.
Do you think this is a game you tell or just write. Well. There's not there's not a large migration.
Back to the cities. So the essence of miking of rejecting. Living in cities.
Reminds with our now i don't think we are giving up our main.
Of course a lot of the things that we i earlier on might have identified as crucial to.
You know being in the counterculture like having schooling air and kids.
And those sorts of things many of those ideals.
Many of us have dropped many of those ideals but some of us still have them. But. I will all wise.
Identify myself with this tribe as long as i can go to events.
Where i meet the people that i've managed and loved for twenty years and where we sing and dance together
and smack a bit of sorts of things which. I feel i'm most fortunate to be able to do. Most people.
Middle class people in a fairly. Upwardly mobile. Sort of social situation have to travel and move and.
My career moves and. And i don't think that i can remind usually a part of a tribe the while i've been able to remind.
Part of the trauma. From a growing old with this bunch of people. Is just an absolute traitor.
So i will never same like a fire to me as long as we all gather.
Even if a tiny three or four times a year at various events. But it certainly. That's still happening with enough.
Frequency for me to feel totally identified still with the movement. That is what. Well. We. We wanted to leave.
As closely intertwined with a child as lives as we could we really did. Yeah. Card. Well when we set up.
Paradise valley pastoral company. We in our naivety i guess.
We really dreamed that we would all grow old together there. That was the dream.
But rather than being mom and dad and the kids.
Moving about the country because of various peoples occupations and getting together with our brothers and sisters.
At christmas time. We would stay together and live together and work together as much as we could. To gether.
It was an absolutely beautiful dream so we would eat together. And we would buy together.
And although we'd have separate bedrooms and sorts of things by unlogged. Al living time. Would be with a child.
As a small hamlet of people. Rather than mom and dad and the kids. The sharing of. The money that was of course not.
Possible. There was really know why. Of exchanging money for sweat. And in the beginning.
You know i put in a lot more money than sweat and other people put in a lot more sway than money in the long run.
It was very difficult for us to try to balance things out. And we shared. Less and less money.
And sweat as time went by it was just not possible for us to do that dream. And we shared less of a child as. Communal.
Lives too as time went by so gradually somebody will build a little kitchen or somebody would build a little.
Living room. So instead of having bedrooms and everything else be shared. Sometimes. One family would eat.
On there are no one couple would eat on their own and communal life. Gradually chinese need to really live.
And in the end that's what. Paradise valley is it's now a village. Rather than a commune. But the mere fact that.
Twenty to thirty people can actually share. The ownership of land. Is not a bad fate.
And in the spirit and what communal money there is on rudd's and by sick facilities. Is still working there.
What paradise valley didn't have all along. Was some deep spear. Ritual. Connection.
And a spiritual connectedness between all the members.
Whereas one or two of the other communities because paradise valley was one of the first six two of the.
Six dominant are and body found.
Did have a deep sort of spiritual commitment and i felt for a while as if that was going to my be how they mean a more.
Communal style of life than paradise valley but in the event. All of the.
Multiple occupancies of now become multiple occupancies and they are rather.
Villages rather than anything that people would usually understand
when i talk about a commie in just a villages of friends of loch minded frames with. Fairly similar ideals.
Who have a capacity to exchange swit. But the exchange of money for sway. Has still. I think defeated. Most of us.
When we've tried to do. What's. It's almost just. Tautological decided we couldn't overcome air conditioning.
You know i was plenty of money so i could pass i some of the people.
To do some work for me and for us at quite a reasonable right. Per hour. But there was no why.
I could pif for somebody else to do something for me or for the farm. At the simon alley right.
That i was getting bigger if the alley right i was getting as a doctor was absolutely extraordinary. And.
I certainly didn't feel like prying the right that i was getting.
For the other lie by it's possible that if i'd felt like doing that. It might have worked out.
But i didn't feel like doing that.
And the amount of money involved would have been extraordinary it would have looked and felt quite bizarre.
But doing it any other why in the long run didn't work either.
So in the end we couldn't do that sort of exchange i couldn't put money into the community purpose.
Instead of working for a die etc etc etc just didn't work out like that. I think i did.
I did a pretty good job of that. I i worked. I didn't work a name been. Bicycling. I worked in lee's more here.
Well i kind the fact that i was ice psychiatrist and indeed the army psychiatrist for miles around.
Somehow didn't have don't think it impacted rightly on my life and i don't think it impacted.
Terribly importantly on the community. Except that i grew to have a close friendship with the local policeman.
Which might in the event. I think of been quite helpful and. Early in the pace. His capacity to tolerate deviance.
I think was increased.
To some extent by the fact that he knew i was a reasonable blood he knew that i worked in the context of my working in
the local city lismore. I was a respected. And. Ordinary.
Well known all around when i was a consultant i was a specialist working in town.
Sour i was one of the sort of senior doctors in there and even though.
You know like superman i chinas into my hippie gear once i got back to name them. I think the. The relationship that.
I therefore had with that guy i think was quite helpful. In his capacity to tolerate davy and so not to try to police.
The area. Why he otherwise. Might have. And i think that would be probably the. The mine why. In which.
I as a psychiatrist. Had some sort of influence on the plies it was an indirect y. By in a sense giving the policeman.
Permission. You know not to get his knickers in a knot about this weird situation.
That was happening there and of course he would have now died too which would have helped.
I think in him not becoming obsessed about. About that part of the how.
Process as well as far as the community work and you know the rest of the tribe are concerned.
But i certainly didn't use me as any sort of counsellor or regard me as having any particular wisdom because.